hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry fear the holy crap I
loaded up the game before you even got a
chance to recording listen ok I'm
currently in the hole that go deeper in
the hole okay
this way this way everything's fine
everything's fine Oh give me the heebie
jeebie
ha ha you all wait I don't have any ammo
do I go for that gun it doesn't help me
much do I shoot this thing
maybe I see a head there hey let me aim
right for the head I'm wasting ammo
aren't I I'm not gonna kill this thing
ah
got ya [ __ ] damn it what the hell was
that supposed to be hey I got it can I
go through here
Oh what aah it's got like a fail-safe oh
I did just waste a time I didn't I maybe
I'm supposed to go back after I get the
gun uh uh uh uh take care of you fight
fists of fury [ __ ] aah oh you want some
of this [ __ ] oh what's that huh oh oh
you an a-hole I couldn't agree more
miss me dick aah aah
I my kid I hate yo fine we're going
straight up here I'll give a [ __ ] you
obviously look at all the [ __ ] I don't
give a bow all right got my way I got
business to take care of I just spent
all of my bullets on scabby
ah ball no oh okay good I can still get
him
hi oh you want some too I don't have
time to reload so I'm just go it slapped
up [ __ ] out of you cause that poor
little baby died after a few punches to
the face but a wuss Oh take everything
on with my fists ah
nothing's harmless okay what did I get
here here to reload my gun eh I can just
run by that guy I don't need to shoot
him huh
yeah this guy too huh
Nazneen how's it hanging so far knock
knock I'm okay
I knew something was bad it couldn't be
that easy mother
five okay ah ah oh come on this doesn't
look good
none of this start looking different
beginning I don't know ah ah dead end
ah dun goofed huh dun goofed haha go we
don't wanna ha ha ha he's gonna get me
why these times it's like SCP OMB I kept
going down the wrong way and dying
instantaneously get the [ __ ] out ah
baller not baller I'm the opposite of
baller right now I'm ball negative ha ha
it's so so horrible in here
hello revolver rounds I don't remember
there being a revolver in the game I
don't remember that at all remember
where the door is located on the street
we really need those weapons down here
so hurry whoa ok what weapons what
street what door I even know where I'm
going right now how do you expect me to
remember the door in the street
where am I going right now by the by
just as an aside I am kind of curious
for my own survival hello is anybody in
this maze with me how about I guess yeah
I'm gonna uh yeah yeah ha ha ha my god
jeez lady we all got problems
why you gotta be screaming man handle
your balls I guess I scream fairly often
so I can't really complain huh No so
feel you okay you okay Sophia top Sophia
my love oh what's that
save please let me say don't scare me
no Gary was that way did I do loop
around in a big circle please tell me
I'll kick in maze exit oh oh oh
where's my timer I don't even know where
my timer when we're my timer okay all
right
do these tunnels ever end no you're in
the hole hahaha [ __ ] what was that what
the balls are you why are you what are
you oh ha oh he's bad on me Oh what is
that
Jesus holly balls not that way
Oh God what the hell was all that oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa
hi hi hi hi how about Chuck back out how
about you [ __ ] off huh miss me got your
gun bullets man I don't know what they
did in this particular custom campaign
but it is like either I've forgotten how
terrifying cry fear was or I am I am in
the worst nightmare of my life
we're down there but down there who's
down there
oh you I don't care about you jeez
conure aah
these these these guys be trippin yo
nothing doesn't seem right
ought to be something man it's a
freaking maze everywhere I go I know I
see you in there
I see you in there I'm not going that
way screw you and screw all that you
care about hope you die by my gun cuz
it's not just the job guys
I hate that breathing it's not just a
job scares it's like everything is extra
atmosphere I don't know who made them
those of
the the music of cry fear but he is an
evil genius diabolical evil genius I'm
gonna run out of bullets but I'm not
gonna waste in this town
hello you know I was always told than
any original cry fear there was in fact
a sort of flashlight you could put onto
your pistol but I never found it then
again I didn't look very hard I was too
busy running away from the monsters hey
you in the water I'm gonna punch the
[ __ ] out of you ha ha
Oh what that you're free ain't gonna
help you
ah too quick for you ha ha
get ready go beep house down
Oh world champion uh that's two more in
there I know
let me just rely my gun wiggler okay
there we go
now back to bullets please splish hi ha
there's so many of you betcha
not there we go
gosh you're also numerous you gotta be
kidding me no no I can't I can't get it
just the frickin wha where am I
what the ha ha I'm alive I'm amazing
I'll have it with my weapons reaching
there I might have panicked a bit but I
am incredible what damn I'm good
damn I'm good all right not burst fire
single shot thank you
it's a little dark so I'm gonna get out
my flashlight and then I'll blindly
shoot at whatever attacks me that's
always a good strategy okay okay okay
okay
everything got quiet which is definitely
not a cause for worry I'm definitely
gonna be fine now Oh what's this does a
valve need to go here I would assume so
I love valve comes great this it's way
too quiet it's way too quiet
aha holy crap you're big oh you're so
big you think I don't need to kill you
what the hell oh I'll just jump over it
like a [ __ ]
I jumped over it I did you all saw you
all saw come a gun no you can't assault
rifle flashlight combo I don't think
haha [ __ ] you
good crazy what am i what am I supposed
to do
what am i what am I doing here there
wasn't really anything over on the other
side maybe what I timer not working
right all right I don't
I want like before in between saves I
don't have quite enough time so I'm just
gonna pause it here so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
dominus house is terrible whoever
designed it Bonaparte
Rose go nowhere oh [ __ ] Oh God Oh